hello there this is linfa wang
and i'm the professional director from
the program in emerging infectious
disease
at the duke national university
singapore medical school in singapore
it's my pleasure to have this
opportunity to present you on the topic
of
challenges and the role of serology
in the next phase of copy 19 responses
so this is a brief outline you know
i hope most of the uh audience will be
very familiar with the kovi 19 outbreak
so it would i would really
go through very briefly and then maybe a
few slides on the disease in the
virology
and then i would present the challenges
i think you know
uh are there for the next phase of
outbreak
but the bulk of the talk is really on
the role of serology
so in terms of outbreak you know it's
been going on for six months now it
starts in
december 2019
and as as all for yesterday we have
already over seven million infections
and uh close to 430
deaths and i have to say you know i have
been working this field for the last 25
years and i was in wuhan
in january uh 2020
but i even myself would never predict it
you know there's two things
really sort of caught us by surprise one
is this
speed of spread and the number of
infected uh
people all around the world secondly as
you can see
is the dark you know the color is that's
the epicenter
and nobody would have predicted right so
these are the areas you know
like in usa can be affected so
uh badly in terms of the major events
you know we already know that
you know early december might be the
starting of
circulating the virus in gohan and by
january 7th
china cdc uh eliminated to say it's not
sas
it's not amin flu but it's a novel
chronovirus and the first test was the
regis january 11th and then in thailand
the first
export case is basically from china and
the who
declared a global health emergency on
sirius
jam and uh you know the virus was named
as such chronologists ii
and then march 11 was wh declared as
pandemic
on these times of scare there's two
important events you know for scientists
i think it's really important for
scientists like myself one is actually
that on january 11th or 12th is the
first genome sequence become publicly
available
you know in this day and age whether you
want develop diagnosis
all vaccine sequences are absolutely
essential
and then another important day is on
january 20th because that's the date
basically that the chinese authority uh
announced that there's human human
transmission once the virus is
capable or known to have a human human
transmission then the whole world
take it much more seriously early on
there was a debate about this
new outbreak is it sas or not size
i always say it depends on what you want
to your focus
if you focus on the disease then sas is
severe acute
respiratory syndrome and we know for
cov19 now
more and more data comes out is majority
of patients present
with mild disease and now this high
proportion is asymptomatic
so in this regard then i think the
original
claim is right that it's not sas
but if you look at the virus and the
virus the genome is 80
identical to the source chronovirus and
involves
taxonomy you know we have four levels we
go from the you know
orders to families to genus and to
species
so this virus is in the same species as
such chronovirus and the species name is
sas related
chronomars so i always use the
analogy for humans right we are all one
species in different strain
you know so different ethnic background
so in this case
sas and kovi 19 are the same virus just
different strain
most people are familiar now with this
computer general image
so it's a beautiful virus with the
spikes on the surface the name comes
from this crown like if you do a section
cut through the virus and then the spike
protein present
on the ring it's like a cross that's why
it's called chronovirus
and the key proteins on the membrane
surface is this
spike protein which is uh responsible
for receptor binding and
fusion with the host membrane and
the genome is large you know so it codes
for the spy protein in grain
and then the nucleic capsule in bronze
and then the e and
m proteins so these are four structure
proteins and the others are called
orfs so they are non-structured proteins
the genome is huge you know rna virus
usually have small genomes because the
eyelid polymerase has a low fatality so
that
usually you could not maintain a large
genome but coronavirus is exception
so the genome size is around 30 kilobase
and it's the largest genome
for any known rna virus sasco v2
is seems to be also genetically more
stable than the other two
uh coronal viruses the zoonotic
chronomers chromos and the most
chronomars
it uses the same receptor as such
chronological
the ac2 on human cells but with a high
affinity
so this has been you know speculate
maybe explain
why the kovi 19 virus is more
transmissible than the science virus and
in terms of origin you know we don't
know for sure yet but
most likely it's another backbone virus
because a group in china already
discovered there's a bad virus
which is a 96 overall genome identity to
this
size chronologist too and the question
whether there's a
in the media host we don't know but a
virus has been discovered in pangolin
you know so
again it's a kovi 19 relative virus the
overall genome
identity is not as high as the back
but it's being discovered that actually
the key receptor binding domain
of the spy protein is more related than
the bad virus
so this is showing in the next slide so
this is the paper you know in nature
published a few weeks ago now
and the pharogeni on the right is that
in the pink box basically these are all
cov19
related virus and the human virus is the
main one
and the red dot marked the virus that
discovered in different
pangolin studies but the red arrow
indicates this is the virus coming from
back so the back virus is still
more related to the human virus than the
pangolin virus
interestingly so for those of course you
could not read the chinese i apologize
but this is the menu from the juan and
see for the market you know was very
famous because
the early uh cases seems to be all
linked to that
uh seafood market and
so this is the menu in chinese as you
can see there's a lot of
animals or meats are sold but
not pangolin okay so the red bugs
indicate that actually it's a civic so
civics we know is a highly susceptible
response for the transmission
of sas coronavirus in 2002 2003 so it's
an intermediate host
but for kobe 19 we still don't know
whether an intermediate
uh animal host is involved and which is
the
what is the animals we still don't know
so in terms of challenges you know there
are many but
i want to focus on three challenges
really to contrast kobe 19 to science
for sas chronologist outbreak you know
it's lasted totally around six months
and with just over a thousand infections
and 774
death the virus basically of the
pandemic
was contained or eradicated by july 2003
now in contrast we know that you know
this is
old number so we already have over 7
million infections and
above 430 you know death already
so the chance of contamin containment or
eradication
is slim you know it's not zero
right so what we need now the challenge
number one
is access strategy that's we did not
face during startup break
challenge number two is that obviously
vaccine will be
a very important part of this effective
exit strategy
but we are still a long way away from a
licensed human vaccine
but before even the vaccine comes on
market we really need to get
our you know tools and knowledge it's
really to uh
lift our game is because the coloration
of protection is
still poorly understood and also the
longevity of protect immunity
will not be known until a few years
later right we cannot start longevity
without actually let a recovered patient
run through the process
but maybe there is a little bit sort of
a good news
if we think sas chronological
are so close related virus if the human
immune response
are similar as well then we have some
good news so our group
just published this paper a few weeks
ago we checked
the uh patient zero from sas survivors
in singapore so these are the
patients that infected 17 years ago and
we take the blood from donors
and we compare their neutralizing
activities you know with the
serum that we have archived so that
in 2003 and we defined them as
convalescence here
less than one year old and then we have
convolution zero
you know in the table as you can see
nine years 14 years and 17 years
so if you focus on the nine to 17 years
and to the south chronovirus as you can
see
that majority of these survivors still
have quite
high neutralizing antibodies so that's
hopefully is a little bit good news
if the kobe 19 immune response resembles
that of
sas patients
challenge number three to do with
animals as i said you know
we believe it's most likely uh
a bad virus but the intermediate host
is not known right whether there is
hidden
then different from sars you know sas as
i said you know is
relatively uh contained and
did not spread too far and
but for kovi 19 now we have this
concern about this spirit back or
reverse to not
transmission so we think initially the
virus was
animal to human jump but now there are
over seven million people
involved in fact some of this these
infected humans will have close contact
with animals
there's a chance for this transmission
from human to animal what we call spear
back or reverse
transmission and this is a
report just came out of science so for
those of you not aware that you know
in the mink farms in the netherlands now
there is a pretty bad
outbreak of kovi 19. and this
is clear spear back or reverse
zoonotic transmission and to a certain
degree it's not a surprise because
mint is related
you know ferrous right and we know that
ferrets are quite
susceptible uh to these viruses and also
to flu you know so
so this is the space we need to watch
out the other concern
is that it may spear back to bats but at
a geo
different geographic location so for
example in north america you know
we are already concerned whether the
human infection can
result in a spear back of this virus
into bat populations
and then really form a new reservoir in
a different geographic location
so this is sort of the bulk of my talk
is that i have been you know a focus on
serology
since day one as soon as we heard the
kobe 19 outbreak
because i believe that serology in the
late phase
of the kobe 19 response will play a very
major role so here i just listed some of
these
you know challenges we're facing right
you heard of this you know hurdle
immunity how much we have to get
in the hood immunity before we can stop
the transmission
some countries are considering the exit
strategy is to issue immediate passport
as i said the longevity of the protect
immunity we still don't know
and convalescent plasma is being used as
a therapy
but we don't know you know whether any
patients
convalescent plasma is good enough and
then once we have a vaccine then
efficacy at both individual and
population level
and then we have the animals so the top
five are human really applications
in red and the next two
dot points are in blue are to do with
animals you know so
whether we want to search for natural
reservoir or intermediate host or
monitor possible the risk of reverse
nautic transmission
this in all these areas serology will
play a very important role but we need
to
really go beyond just detect antibodies
what we need
for the red five dot points is really
have a serology which can detect
functional antibodies or neutralizing
antibody
for the the blue dot point for animal
studies then what we need
is a serology test which is a species
independent basically we don't know
which animals we're going to test
right and so we don't want to develop a
specific sorority for each animal that
we want to test
so here is again this diagram of the
virus
and the genome structure when a virus
infected hosts whether it's animal or
human it will
induce lots of antibodies hundreds if
not thousands
and for large viruses like chronoviruses
you know of course the antibody will be
directed to all sorts of different
proteins and different domains
but these what we call our binding
antibodies
right as i said you know in the previous
slides you know for
most of the next phase response we want
to know the neutralizing antibodies
unfortunately nutrients antibodies is
always going to be a minority so for
chronovirus that may be
one to five percent and we know that the
spike protein is involved in virus you
know binding to the
receptor and the fusion with the cell
membrane
so this is the main target the green
protein the grain one spike is the main
target
and within the spike there's a domain
called the receptor bonding domain now
is highlighted in red bar
so this is a very important domain
because that's where it makes the
interaction with the human ac2 receptor
and it's
even more important in terms of detect
neutralizing antibodies
so currently the gold standard of
detecting neutralizing antibodies
is using live virus okay so
this is a diagram on the left you have a
virus
in know docking onto the receptor in
this case is ac2 and then
start this entry process followed by
replication
infection in the presence of
neutralizing antibody on the right
of this uh diagram the uh diagram
what the neutralizing amplitude does is
that they can block that docking
and then prevent infection
so the advantage is that it's highly
specific
okay the disadvantage is that for kobe
19 it's a
biosafety level three pathogens so you
have to have a bss three before you can
do it
and it's tedious in a slow takes three
to five days and it requires highly
skilled
uh stops because the rate the readout is
not as simple
so you need not only a facility you need
a
really special equipment but also that
the readout
you know for example this is the true
photo we have taken
on the sale is that in the presence of
neutralizing antibodies the cell is
healthy
but without natural antibody it caused a
cytopathic effect on cpe
but for you know untrained eyes you know
you look
very similar it looks very similar so to
solve that you know really to
you know address these challenges we
develop a surrogate virus neutralization
test
so this really addressed both uh
challenges
by determining these neutralizing
antibodies but also
in a species independent manner okay
so the invention itself
you know on the theoretical level is
very very simple
so this is a different version with a
diagram i just show you so this is now
the chronovirus here
and this is the spy protein on the left
in blue
and interact with the ac2 receptor in
purple
and then on the right side if you have
the neutralizing antibodies in the dark
brown color
that will bind to the rbd receptor
binding domain of the spy protein
which will prevent the binding to the
ac2
and achieve a neutralization so what we
did
is basically about chemical stimulation
we do away with live virus and we don't
need a cell
so what we did is using protein
engineering basically
so both the spy protein and the ac2 are
membrane proteins
so in order to do biochemical simulation
we have to engineer protein which is not
membrane bond
soluble so that's what's on the right
okay
the right and the bottom left so what we
have now is we only express the the brew
head the receptor binding domain rather
than the whole spy protein
to make the life is even easier we
chemically conjugate with the
horseradish
peroxidase that's enzyme ubiquitously
used in elisa
assays so we chemically conjugate this
so this is
indicated in yellow and so we have hip
ibd conjugate at the bottom the line is
the
the bottom of the elisa plate well and
as you can see
we coated with the ac2 but now the ac2
is
engineered so we remove the
transmembrane domains it's a soluble
protein as well
so in panel b on the bottom left
so that if you have hip ibd
and you bind to different amounts onto
the ac2
and then you put the substrate you see a
color so it's a those dependent
on the right of panel b in the presence
of neutralizing antibody now it will
bind to the ibd domain and
block the binding of the ac2 so
basically what you're doing
is that reduce or eliminate the color
reaction
so here is the real data so in panel c
is that we use the three proteins the
nuclear capsule protein n
and the s1 half of the spike protein and
then the rbd
so as you can see the m protein was used
as a net control because it does not
bind to ac2
as expected the blue is s1 and the red
dot
is the rbd so rbd gives us the best
binding in a dose dependent manner
in panel d now we tried this
neutralization so this
is a surrogate neutralization everything
is done in an elisa plate where
no libraries no cells no bss3
so as you can see patient one and two in
red and blue
give a beautiful inhibition curve those
depend again
when you dilute it out the inhibition is
gone but the two negatives has no
inhibition so we were really excited
when we saw this data you know
and we thought ac2 is the same receptor
used by both kovi 19 so this is c
panel c and the d is kovy 19 but it
should also work with sas
so in panel e we did exact same thing
now it's a sas chronovirus ibd
in red as well and you can see a
beautiful dose dependent binding
in panel f we did the serial
neutralization
and the two positive size patient and
two negative as you can see again
beautiful reduce dependent
and very specific neutralization
so as i said you know we want to develop
not only a surrogate neutralization test
to measure human antibodies but
also to measure animal antibodies in a
species independent manner
can we do it so these are the data so on
the left is kovi 19 so for kobe 19 we
don't have infected animal cellular in
our hands we use immunized zero
so these are rabbit and the mouse
immunized with
the ibd domain as you can see the nectar
control there was no inhibition
and the positives are beautiful you know
the inhibition is very high
close to 100 percent and can be diluted
out of course in a dose-dependent manner
in panel b now this is the sauce serum
so
i do have some ferrous infected with
salt so this is a natural infection
and also rabbits you know immunized with
a whole
uh enacted device the whole size virus
that was done you know 17 years ago
again beautiful inhibition and none with
the neck
control so basically we have
demonstrated in
three different animal species and two
viruses in a totally species
independent manner so the same assay can
be used basically to test
any zero in a very specific and
sensitive way
now this is important because we already
knew that for
sas chronologists ii that the
human to animal transmission has already
happened in cats dogs
tigers and minks and we know natural
infection happens in the wild with bats
pangolins and the civets
okay so i can you know envisage many
more animals are susceptible
and we need to really do large scale
and a multi-geographic location serology
surveys
to really find out you know cov19
related virus how widely distributed and
whether any of these animals could be
the
intermediate host these informations are
important
to prevent future outbreaks
so when you have a surrogate virus
neutralization and
we want to know how specific it is so we
did some cross reactivity
and as you can see from in panel c you
go from right to
left so panel c we have most
serial which does not inhibit or does
not neutralize this
in the surrogate uh barcelona essay
the 229e nl63 does not work
oc-43 does not sas is interesting
as i said you know we have two groups of
zero right convolution zero
from south survivors in singapore we
have this
in 2003 less than a year convalescent
and we have 2020 more than 17 years of
convalescent
interestingly that the 17-year sierra is
more
cross-reactive so they cross neutralize
the
uh kovi 19 virus to make sure that
these are not sas survivors have been
exposed to kobe 19 which is very
unlikely because in singapore you know
the
population's prevalence of infection is
less than 0.1 percent you know so
for somebody to have a sauce 20 uh 17
years ago and
exposed to kobe 19. but we still want to
make sure that's not the case so this
is what we did so in panel d so this is
the less than one year convolution
series
so now we are doing this surrogate virus
initialization for both kovi 19
and the sas side by side so we should be
able to tell you know which
is it more sauce or more curvy 19. so
clearly
that you know in panel d that they have
very high
uh inhibitions on sas uh
uh surrogate neutralization but not on
the core v19 which is in
blue but in panel e that 17 years later
as you can see
overall the gray dots are the sas
uh uh surrogate large neutralization so
the neutralizing antibody to the south
virus has
dropped a little bit 17 years later but
still there
and then but some individuals have
increased now kovi 19 cross
neutralization so it's a very
interesting observation
the mechanism we don't know yet but i
think more research needs to be done
okay so another you know question
reviews really asked about is that you
claim this is a surrogate virus
neutralization and how
well does it call with live vast
neutralization right
so currently we have uh you know two
live virus neutralization one is using
this
uh kovi uh 19 virus and it has to be
done in bss3 so this is the correlation
curve as you can see
on the x axis is the
conventional vars neutralization the
micro var micro neutralization test we
call
c v and t on the y axis is our surrogate
virus neutralization
and as you can see the correlation is
pretty good r squared is a point
0.86 approximately
we also did this with a
pseudo virus so the pseudo virus
and we call pvnt on the x axis and the y
is still s v and t and the r square is
around point a three so
similar you know not as good or maybe as
the live virus but it's very similar
okay so we went ahead and used human
series
both in singapore and china so we had a
200 nectar series in blue
and the red you know 170
something samples in singapore and the
50 in china
as you can see panel d and the e that
the specificity in both cases 100
and the sensitivity varies from 98 to 99
so i have to stress that these are
convalescent
human serums a pcr confirmed
okay so as some of you may
know in the audience that uh
for kovi 19 patients that not everyone's
serial convert
so there are people get infected by
doing zero convert
okay so another question is to say now
your surrogate virus neutralization is a
good idea but you're only measuring
antibodies targeted to the rbds are you
going to miss non-rbd binding
neutralizing antibodies
so specifically there are several
scenarios one is that
in the s protein you have the s2 domain
for example
from the sas studies they have
demonstrated some of the s2 antibody can
also play a role in neutralization and
recently that you know
neural peeling has been identified as a
potential you know
a a co-receptor so where the core
receptor play role with ibd will
interact with that
and also that you know for in general
varsity neutralization can happen post
attachment post entry so i would say the
answer to this question is yes in theory
but on the operation operational level
if you're measuring neutralizing
antibody using zero e6 then
none of these will play a major role and
so
just a few days ago there's a science
translational medicine paper
journal publisher paper they did a very
detailed
really immunization step studies and
then they found that
you know the s ibd domain not the s2
really generates strong neutrons and
antibodies
uh our own studies also demonstrate that
so this
is another you know correlation so this
is a
a cvnt core with svnt i have already
shown in the data
and now one caller is the cvnt called
with the
pseudo virus so the pseudovirus is the
four-length spy protein
whereas our surrogate large
neutralization use the ibd
if the anti-s2 antibody plays a major
role you will see the
difference right the pseudo-virus will
perform much better
in correlation with the live virus but
it's not
as you can see the correlation r squared
is 0.86 and here is 0.77
so if if anything that our rbd actually
based the uh surrogate virus
neutralization performs
queries with the live virus
neutralization better
than the pseudovirus which is you know
based on the full
length spy protein so that's also
indicate that
ibd really is the major neutralization
sort of a domain and the correlation at
operation level is really
good the other question is can antibody
testing predict protect immunity you
know that's a
really uh in the news all the time so
basically you can split into two
questions one
is that binding antibodies does it equal
to neutralizing antibodies and we know
it doesn't
secondly is that neutralizing antibody
level does that
equal to protect immunity and we would
say that you know
approximately you can use that as
estimation a few days ago last week now
so when the madonna vaccine you know uh
announced the press uh release uh tony
fortune
made this statement to say you know the
exciting thing is really
they didn't did not just show binding
antibody but they should neutralize
anybody then he
went on to say that you know that will
predict you know
protect immunity and and it's a
reasonable assumption that neutralizing
antibody well
equal to protect immunity okay so that's
what we try to demonstrate you know
surrogate mass neutralization
differs from all the other antibody
tests even if you use ibd as antigen
in a commercial test whether it's elisa
or
rapid test you are detect binding
antibody
so in order to differentiate the normal
elisa
and our svnt so we did this
study so we use the mouse monochrome
antibody
four of them and on the left is eliza
panel a is binding as you can see all
four mono
antibodies have a good binding and a
dose dependent panel b
is the surrogate mass neutralization
inhibition so as you can see the red one
for example has a very
that monoclonal has a very strong
bonding in panel a
it's a neutralization negative in our
test so
our tests can really differentiate
between bonding and neutralizing
antibody
and we are truly measuring neutralizing
antibody and this is a human monoclonal
antibodies again four of them
and then this time as in panel g as you
can see this a
yellow monochrome has a strong binding
and on the
panel h in neutralization it's negative
one thing we're really surprised you
know to to also observe
is that when you put these two
neutralizing antibodies together so this
is the blue and the green
so when you put the bruno green you
should get an average so the
predicted value is this dotted line in
gray
but instead what we get is the solid
line in purple
so what we're seeing is something called
the neutralization
synergy or neutralization epitome
synergy so when you have antibodies bind
to
different neutralization epitomes they
can have a synergy
okay so we think we have seen this for
human serum as well so these are the
human serum from singapore that we
functionally divide them into from eliza
with rbd
we have four different groups so if you
go from the bottom
to the right first panel d which has
high
igg and high igm as you can see they
have a very strong
inhibition and they have a titration
curve you know so
really sort of curves upward and then
you have a high
in panel c you have high igg low igm
as you can see still very good panel a
now you have high igm and low igg
the curve inhibition is good good but
the
titration you know the the job is faster
so the curve has a
slope it's a sharp slope and then you go
to panel b
which is low ignore low igm it still
have
a good inhibition from 70 to 90 percent
at the low dilution but when you dilute
it out now you can see it drops very
fast
okay but what i try to emphasize is in
panel b
if you use igm igg you know so if you
use this
isotype specific elisa it will all be
classified as
negative or very weak positive but in
our vars neutralization as
we're measuring total and also synergy
if there's a synergy
we will see that so the actually the
neutralization is still
pretty good okay so with that i'm going
to conclude my talk to say
no now we have direct this surrogate
virtualization
which offers many advantages over the
existing serology whether it's elisa
or the virus neutralization it's our
svnt is specifically sensitive it's safe
you don't need a bss three
very fast one hour test and that too if
you want the low throughput you can do
manually or high throughput you can use
the machine
and then can be used for both human and
animals as i said is a species
independent but the key
is that on the market right now this is
the only test capable of
measuring true neutralizing antibodies
without the need for any live materials
virus or cells
and definitely no bio containment is
required
so with that i'd like to thank you and i
do have a conflict interest declaration
because we have a patent
on this technology and a commercial kit
is being marketed right now
and thank you for your attention